i was hanging out with busta rhymes uh
he was playing
he had a little intimate little
extension level event to uh
listening thing and he was just so cool
man
i was like because i like ran into him
in other places and try to like had i
had people that know him like you know
introducing yeah and he seemed like
he kind of seemed like a dick of course
i mean listen when you're in the game
30 years bro you've seen it all done and
i kind of feel like there's some days
where you're just like no i get it
bothered with this [ __ ] just make sure
nobody talks to me i don't want to take
[ __ ] pictures and and i could see now
with those
you know it takes a lot of energy even
now mental mental energy yeah no that's
the most it takes everybody wants what
they want they don't give a [ __ ] if
you're having a bad day like yo let me
get a picture man bing bong yeah that
gives no [ __ ] yeah it's kind of it gets
you mental and and i can see how uh
i'm i consider myself strong-minded i
could see how somebody that already
would have like
issues
could fold you know what i'm saying
because it does get there's there's
times when i'm out places and and i'm
not i'm not eminem i'm not drake you
know i could see what the they can't
even go outside but i see
there's times where like i want to leave
and i'm stuck
i need this big picture picture picture
like i can't go this way that way this
way whatever and it's like all right
this is what i always wanted so this is
what you wanted this is what i wanted
it's cold and you're go you got to be
glad that it happened to you now
absolutely and now when you had like
drug problems you were like really
always i always feel like
recently i've been thinking about that a
lot like for years i was like oh damn i
was i had
i had opportunities with shady i had
opportunities with def jam why didn't
that happen now for years i was
questioning myself why didn't that
happen
it's clear to me now it's like i would
have [ __ ] killed myself you weren't
right or killed somebody you know what
i'm saying like
it would have it would have ended badly
whatever whatever way it would have went
it would have ended badly and uh you
know that just
shows that everything happens for a
reason it don't happen when you wanted
to it happens when it's supposed to
whatever the reason whatever the reason
is
you know
[ __ ] is not gonna happen on your time it
happens on
god's time or the universe's time
whatever you choose to call it and uh
you know
i'm just happy that i'm and lucky that
i'm blessed i got a mother who prays for
me every day i have good family and
people around me that make sure you feel
like you're always at the same squat
around you yeah is it pretty easy for
you to like because i know you had some
sort of struggles we talked about the
last time you hear what it was sobriety
and [ __ ] but now that you're popping
there's more money there's more cool
[ __ ] going on around you has it been
like have you been pretty have you ever
been tempted to like get back into some
[ __ ] [ __ ] or [ __ ] always been around me
like like alcohol
weed that [ __ ] is always around me you
know what i'm saying i'm not one of
those people that don't do any that
don't do drugs or drink that be like nah
you can't do that around me i don't i'm
not a party please do what you got to do
that [ __ ] i know what's good i know
what's good for me what works for me
and i know that if
i take a drink i'm somebody that can't
do one of anything but i can't do one
blunt one drink
[ __ ] one dollar one woman
i'm saying like like i always got to do
things and [ __ ] exercise
so i already know there's no myth there
i know that if you if i choose to take a
drink i'm gonna drink until i get drunk
and throw up if i smoke i'm gonna smoke
blunts all [ __ ] day if i pop a pill
i'm gonna pop
non-stop and so i'm [ __ ] passed out
you know what i'm saying yeah if i
[ __ ] sniff if i sniff some coke bro
i'm gonna [ __ ] go on a month-long run
and nobody's gonna see me you know what
i'm saying have you ever been on a
month-long coke run yeah not coke rum
but just a month-long just dropped
life for drug of garbage head you know i
did everything i mean i didn't smoke
crack like we talked about i didn't
shoot needles but i did everything bro
and not you know i was on a [ __ ]
eight year run how about that
now i've had family members that we just
like we just wouldn't see for like two
months yeah well that's how it gets my
like my aunt would just drop off her
kids with my grandparents
and just see you
well that's how it gets
and it's not even necessarily because
that's what you plan to happen or you
want to happen is just what what happens
what i'm saying it's not because
you know if you listen if you've got
somebody in your life that's doing drugs
or addicted and you feel like they're
doing it to you personally don't take it
like that it's not like i could tell you
from experience like i never wanted to
[ __ ] family members over or [ __ ] friends
over it's just you know we're not doing
that purposely it's just
it's kind of what happens that's what
happens man yeah now i've had
you know my cousin steals [ __ ] from me
and i mean
yeah it's just almost like i
you know it's not the real them i guess
yeah
that's real though it's hard not to take
it personal after that
big time crazy of course i'm gonna take
that [ __ ] matt personal now that i'm on
the other side yeah take that's your mad
person i don't give a [ __ ] what you got
going [ __ ] your life but i'm just
[ __ ] fought five crackheads right
outside the gate he's my friend we're
smoking fentanyl right like right here
on the side that's crazy brothers they
were i feel like [ __ ] now in la
it's probably everywhere
they got that fentanyl
you know we talk about like [ __ ] being
spike with fat and all no now
[ __ ] are doing that's what they
want yeah they're like i don't know i
need the fentanyl give me the fetty
water i spoke to a homeless person he
was a fiend and he said something about
fed like yeah i knew i knew i was i
smoked fat i said smoke i thought that
[ __ ] kills you when you do it he was
like nah we put in the tin foil and
smoking now and then she gets you man
high [ __ ] up i'm like yo so you
actually go out and look for fat no no
you're not looking for crack you're not
looking for purges you're just looking
for fennel death it's insane
that's just playing with your life it's
crazy yeah